au lieu de rentrer aujourd'hui se trouve
sur la version 0.03 de l'alfa c'est
parti on va chercher une partie que j'ai
fait avant allez on y va au go nous
sommes de retour alors ya quelques
nouveautés dans cette mise à jour en mon
dieu j'ai une tête par contre je n'ai
pas de cheveux soit je suis bruce willis
soit je suis eisenberg soit je suis
voldemort oh mon dieu oh pas trop bon
allez c'est parti alors nouveauté
provient de voter eux
malheureusement il ya un nouveau bateau
appelé le house boat donc la maison
bateau voilà qui a l'air est d'être le
bateau le plus stylé du monde il faut
soit 25 bois pour le faire ce qui m'a
peu près deux jours et demi dans la
vraie vie
malheureusement on peut pas le placer
voilà donc on peut pas le faire et là
c'est là que vous êtes censés être tous
tristes un moyen moi y compris
on va tenter aujourd'hui de faire
quelque chose d'extraordinaire un piège
à la peine y à mon dieu j'ai trop la
d'indigènes mort au pied d'un arbre qui
s'est passé ne voit rien lapin viens là
ok c'est parti on entre dans une
terrible non mais tu triches faisait du
bateau sous l'avion et ou alors on
ramasse tout de suite ce gros lézard en
fait moi ce que je voulais faire je vous
le dis mon idée principale de cette
vidéo c'était de faire un élevage de
lapins voilà je compose que de mettre un
piège à lapins ici est de construire je
tiens vraiment à faire ce piège et a
capturé un lapin vivant regardez ils
courent ils nous narguent m'avait dit
mon gars on va voir qui va narguer qui
au nom
il est passé juste avant qu'on ne
construise mais c'est un piège à la part
ou saint piat à temps c'est un piège à
obèses mais pourquoi parce que dans les
pièges que j'aimais regarder comment une
armée bâti aux gars qu'est ce que tu
fais là
bon ok c'est sa cour on reviendra demain
matin voir s'il ya des petits lapins qui
se sont pris les pieds dans la corde ou
tu verras squatter mon voeu douves des
squats et voilà voilà c'est ça c'est ça
la notorité oh mon dieu encore quelqu'un
demande c'est quoi des médicaments qui
volent bas merci mon gars ah ben voilà
les valises des trucs qui font plaisir
un peu et à toutes les valises dans
lesquels je trouve plein de trucs utiles
par exemple des [ __ ] de balles de
tennis sur lui que tu envoies sur les
mouettes et elle s'en bat les steaks on
peut le dire j'ai entendu des bruits de
pas non c'est toi balle de tennis qui
m'est revenue elle veut jouer à la balle
en fait tu leur envoyais te renvoient
elles sont vous en plein vol non bon
c'est chiant quand on a froid bien
j'espère qu'un jour on pourra se
fabriquer chez pas un manteau extra
chauds à base de peau de mouette ou un
truc comme ça quoi et là dedans donc je
peux mettre des des lapins mais comment
comment je les prends pour les mettre
dedans enfin
à jusqu'à jr preuve du contraire la page
peut juste faire peut-être que si
j'avais des médicaments dont ils vont
s'accoupler ça me fera d'autres
médicaments nouveautés incroyable
attention le téléphone mais non non non
non non je sais que vous allez vous dire
mais pourquoi il appelle pas sa maman
pour qu'elle vienne le chercher en
deltaplane et non non ça c'est injuste
at indiqué le nombre de pas que tu as
fait par exemple j'ai fait 650 pas voilà
et ce [ __ ] téléphone n'est même pas
foutu de m'indiquer à température alors
ça c'est un truc que j'ai fait j'ai
toujours pas compris à quoi ça sert on
va le construire
oh [ __ ] j'ai cueilli un mec c'était un
vieux stick bon alain ducasse koala ça
c'était pas des stic
ils sont fins comme des sticks mais
c'est pas des sticks veut rien dire
regardez la elle est nette et estelle
vase il vient attaquer et il paraît
qu'on peut essayer de vivre en harmonie
avec eux alors j'ai des doutes moi
j'étais doute oui toi mon gars tu es à
nous c'est ce à quoi était petite flèche
bas mot 5 ou non vous ne décédez ici
entre ces deux arbres
batta watts il reflue à laver il est
bien mort je crois ne venez pas
m'affronter ou finirait comme lui en
train de vous à coupler avec des plantes
ya des nouveaux os est debout ont semblé
cet accord il ya des nouveaux totems et
la regarder à nouveau avec plein bras
vers le haut il est sympa suis là allez
on va se le faire moi j'ai un totem avec
des bras qui sont vers le haut comme ça
c'est tout plan d'heure
non c'est dégueulasse il ya un mec là
bas on va aller défoncer annoncé un
totem c'est toi la mouette qui a fait ça
1 revient là un tutu plaintes des totems
comme ça bon c'est l'heure d'aller vers
les pièges à lapin a coincé à ce truc ce
sont des fenêtres c'est un banc assez
pour draguer les indigènes
je pense qu'il faut réussir à séduire à
la femme indigène en lui donnant des bep
puis on vient s'asseoir là avec elle et
c'est comme dans les sims après ça finit
dans la mini tank là bas et non ou alors
c'est un lit c'est peut-être un lit un
livre fait maison est ce que vous avez
réussi à chauffer des gens non mais non
mais c'est pas possible alors ça peut
pas choper du lapin attendait non ben
voilà on l'a vu on l'a vu passer il m'a
même fait un don au passage les vues en
fait il veut m'attirer dans mon propos
il s'est passé un truc là mais oui mon
gars messier alors on peut aimer ça va
tuer la pince à parler capturé en vie je
suis triste je pouvais pas faire mon
élevage de lapins ya pas un petit
indigènes pour me faire passer le temps
ah bah ouais il suffisait de demander
alors vas-y attaque moi tu on va sur le
banc ou pas wah wah wah wah wah hausse
des taux se détendent hockey à ma
passion par georges tin rejoint il en
est la droite non attendez on va tourner
autour de mon piège
[ __ ] ça à chaud bienvenu car ce n'est
pas ce dont tu fais pas ton feu y est ça
marche et mon gars sont tous décédés à
breil shu est une jambe échoué qui
rejoint le bras c'est une belle histoire
d'amour qu'on vient de voir
c'est dégueulasse en bouteille d'accord
mais oui mais oui à temps mais [ __ ]
mais il soir ici quoi j'ai raté un truc
sans déconner j'aurais dû rester à côté
on peut pas faire de bons il faut des
pièces en [ __ ] course de tortue ok
moyen qui va gagner qui va gagner je
vais sur celle là celle là mon gars oh
non j'ai pénalisé où ça ça veut dire
vous voulez plus non il faut vraiment
qu'on fasse un tour dans la grotte pour
choper des pièces et faire des bombes à
la recherche et de la grotte des pièces
je peux manger c'était des mauvaises
apte à chaud démangeait 18 quoi ça c'est
des bonnes celles ci mais tu t'es
mauvais ici plus tard elle était moins
les mouettes et nos mails sont toujours
pour nous trouver quoi qu'on fasse
ah je suis désolé elle a peut-être voulu
m'aider [ __ ] j'ai déconné je tue et
moi qui les ai dit je m'en veux oh
une deuxième est arrêté arrêté mais non
il s'est écrasé cette vision d'horreur
il ya une grande pas loin d'ici j'ai pas
un truc à ahmed sur le feu une jambe a
tous envie de cuisiner bien là on va
faire un méchoui avec thé avec tes abdos
et mais là on est super bien faudrait
faire un bon juste à côté d'eux
tente comme ça on peut dire est que
séduire la femme indigène et ensuite il
a tendu sa cote énoncer clairement
déjà on va prendre le pouls experts dans
la main je peux pas m je peux pas mettre
le web faire dans l'âme un bond de l'eau
dedans pourquoi ya huit morts dont
l'inventaire annoncé l son esprit elle
me hante veut me faire culpabiliser
je culpabilise elle veut voler le bomber
attendait mais il ya un gros bug je vais
me sacrifier toutes les bombes
en fait dès que je prends un truc dans
la main ça marche pas hopla fallait pas
passer par là mon gars allaient prendre
la 81e l'accord tel un côté d'ici c'est
maintenant qu'on passe à l' attaque
qu'on se venge
on va récupérer jackson qui sera
probablement autre affaire annonce des
faces avec tous les indigènes où elle a
grandi je sais qu'elle est par là ne
mentez pas elle est ici ah non là c'est
non c'est un bug ça tout à fait de l'
escalade kong a au nom non je suis en
vie mais on trouvera jamais l'entrée de
la grotte sans déconner alors ça c'est
un endroit que j'avais jamais vu avant
et peut-être que j'aurais mieux fait de
ne pas aller le voir
moi je suis mort y est c'est parti on va
tous défoncés à paris elle est déjà là
mais laisse moi tranquille
elle nous chargent quoi je crois qu'elle
est nous charger à les mâcon tête voilà
alors regardons bien où est la grotte
elle est là entre deux pierres il ya un
trou et on va pas juste à côté de mon
été mais non mais à droite était juste
là à côté de noms moi j'ai fait quatre
fois le tour de l'ama pour rien on va
défoncer la femme c'est décidé je sens
sa triple paire de jambes à mort non à
tes pieds meurt mais c'est incroyable
c'est parti vous allez tout est serré
oui il est musclé [ __ ] attentats il me
fait un peu peur lui non tiens au maire
au nom en ange est fâché le muscle et
j'ai flashé vite un peu médicaments pour
reprendre un peu de vie c'est bon elle
est morte et lui sait à quoi par marché
en faisant une posture le body builder
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche mon
gars savaient pas qui tu les vois le
août dernier il s'est caché derrière un
arbre tu crois je t'ai pas deux je sais
qu'elle vient la nature c'est pas la
peine tout accouplé avec quelle est ta
rien fait espèce de nature au fil [ __ ]
rendez-moi jackson le piège bugs
il veut qu'on fasse du limbo les mots je
vais faire du beau avec moi je pense ça
pourra nous apporter par body builder
tuer ce qu'on appelle un stick roues
tuait
maintenant moi aussi tu l'aurais voulu
tu tomberas avec cet arbre jeune
chimpanzé
il va tomber vraiment ou pas il est ou
alors il la descente il est descendu à
meaux à ses news je me trouve avec
accrochée comme ça tombait et non je te
parle à l'aileron d'un tableau qu'est
abbaoui s'effrite mater triste oui les
regards des rampes et et ben voila mon
gars même ce pillage ne fait pas honneur
au lui par contre je crois qu'il a eu
peur boom a à être au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment
et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette quatrième vidéo sur ce fort est
j'espère que ça vous aura plus ces cas
n'était pas aimé la vidéo ça fera un
grand plaisir
la prochaine vidéo que je venais sur ce
jeu sera à la prochaine mise à jour
empêchement une vidéo dessus à chaque
mise à jour donc environ toutes les deux
trois semaines c'est le début des
vacances pour pas mal d'entre vous je
vous souhaite un très bon début de
vacances on se retrouve très vite dans
une nouvelle vidéo tuant tout le monde
et piris et ils s'envolent comme ça
[Musique]